what up space fam goes in here from
anime Opera and I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece Story one
piece is continuing to deliver and shock
with the Luffy vs kaido fight along with
other important character updates so
make sure to stay tuned for this one if
you do enjoy these one piece reviews I
want to keep them coming you know what
to do channel the piricking within and
smash that like button with no mercy
remember smashing his pirate king energy
and passing his scared of Roche energy
so Choose Wisely if you haven't make
this the video subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my huge and
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos on all the yonko Warlords
mythical zones and much more link to
that is in the description and now
without further Ado let's jump into its
spoilers and all Luffy's front and
center in the cover of Shonen Jump which
seems to be positioning one piece my
hero Academia and jiu Jutsu Kaizen as
the big three right now Luffy is a
soccer player and I absolutely love the
Skull and Bones on his jersey crazy to
think how long one piece has ruled this
magazine we get a cover spread and this
time I'm a happy camper since it's my
kind of cover spread we got Nami and
Robin visible and looking fine in their
respective swimsuits Momo's dragon is a
nice touch here as well great Vibes all
around the chapter itself is called the
skies above the capital which we know is
where all of this is taking place on
kaido's flying Castle however since
kaido is getting drained it's not gonna
be in the air for long so Momo has to
set up and produce the flame clouds to
carry it to safety there is little doubt
that he'll accomplish this because of
how much Focus has been placed on it by
the story Yamato is encouraging him but
Momo is still doubting himself saying
easier said than done he thinks it's
impossible the clouds refuse to come out
no matter how hard he tries he's
beginning to lose resolve as he says he
can't with tears in his eyes but then we
get the flashback of that day in the
Burning Castle 20 years ago we jump to
Toki telling her son Momo that he should
go with kinemon and the others she's
certain that Momo will be able to revive
the kozuki clan after he leaps 20 years
into the future now I love time travel
and think this is super cool but part of
me is like kaido will just get stronger
over the next 20 years but I guess what
son got Luffy in the picture it really
doesn't matter Momo is crying and
doesn't want to do it at first he wants
Toki and hiri to go with him but kinemon
tells him to think about his mom's
feelings he tells Momo that no man
should question the result of a woman
who speaks with such conviction and that
nothing could be more shameful and Momo
replies well he's not a man but a child
which is something that's easy for us to
forget and to lose patience with Momo
but we shouldn't the dude is a little
kid and we can't just expect an
eight-year-old to just man up all at
once kinemon continues to remind Momo of
his responsibility now though he says
with Odin that he's no longer just an
heir he wants Momo to give them a chance
to fight kinemon would rather Die With
Honor on the battlefield than wait and
burn to death in the castle he says he
will do anything to wield his sword for
his Lord momonosuke with kinemon bowing
down to him Momo continues to cry but
shows resolve through the tears and says
mother I will be on my way now powerful
stuff and we can imagine how hard this
is for Toki as well who wants to mother
her little boy but also knows what needs
to be done she says yes holding back her
own tears and we jump back to the
present Momo realizes he'll never be
able to face his mom again if he left
things like this with Newfound resolve
he keeps on trying to produce working
flame clouds even though it's not going
that well we jump back to the epic fight
and kaido says to Luffy you grabbed
lightning he laughs at how ridiculous it
is I said last time that he probably
grabbed it but it wasn't clear if he
produced it before or if he just grabbed
it from the sky so now we know he didn't
produce the lightning just grabbed it
from the sky and tunified it so
potentially he can't just produce any
element but we can't say that 100 for
sure he uses gomukomuno Thunderbolt and
throws the lightning like Zeus himself
but kaido just Dodges it which is a bit
anticlimactic after leaving us with that
final panel out last time I really wish
Oda would have let us see that attack
land but perhaps he's building up for a
satisfying attack to happen next chapter
as we'll get into in a bit either way
it's clear that kaido is not messing
around he's not arrogant enough to just
take hits like that anymore and knows he
must avoid them which is a good sign he
even says to Luffy that Luffy can keep
playing around but in the end a strong
devil fruit power isn't enough to
conquer the Seas while he says this he
hits Luffy setting him flying and Luffy
even uses another lightning bolt as a
kind of pull trampoline and bounces off
of it to get back to kaido but it's
interesting what kaido says I think Oda
is talking to the fans who think Luffy
is too overpowered now when it comes to
his double fruit I already said it's
fine because Luffy was always a kind of
chosen one and not everyone who got this
special fruit was good enough to awaken
it but here Oda is making it clear just
because he got to this point doesn't
mean that Conquering the Seas will be
easy kaido goes on to smash Luffy in the
face with his Club adding that Roger had
no fruit power and he still brought the
world to heal Shanks is probably a
similar example of someone who
accomplished a lot without a fruit kaido
says such hurdles are only overcome by
hockey thus kaido confirms that Roger
was probably just an insane hockey
master and that hockey is arguably more
important than even devil fruit Powers
when it comes to Conquering the world as
he's saying this he smashes Luffy again
with death destroyer Thunder bhagwa a
cool note is that this move is a
reference to one of buddhism's wisdom
Kings who is known for besting the god
of death annma epic name and it does
appear to hurt Luffy but Luffy still
managed to grab kaido kaido wants to let
go but using the club is not working he
sends air slices at him and remarks that
it seems like Luffy is still weak to
slashing attacks and we always knew this
buggy D clown is weak to blunt attacks
but not slashes while Luffy is the
opposite you can tell Luffy is in a lot
of pain and props to kaido for actually
using some strategy here and not leaving
that he can just solve everything with
his club we briefly turned to the
festival and although people are smiling
they can't really be happy because they
know it will soon end and they'll be
slaves again they don't even know if
they'll manage to survive for next year
and that's obviously a bummer it goes to
show that partying can be fun but if
life outside of partying sucks then it
doesn't really matter back to the fight
and Luffy has still not let go of kaido
kaido launches a blast breath but Luffy
burnt is still holding on meanwhile
hyogoro is happy to hear the island
that's falling because it means kaido is
at the end of his row he asks what do
they prefer Luffy defeating kaido in the
island falling and them dying or kylo
winning and them only getting a little
longer to cling to life and that makes
it clear to them that it's a no-brainer
especially because they have kids and
wives at home that will be able to live
in peace if Luffy stops kaido even if
they die they'll never be able to repay
Luffy for returning their country to
normal and you love to see them smiling
even as they think the end is near they
all cheer on Luffy while we see kid and
I think he doesn't really know how to
think about this whole thing he has a
pretty funny expression on his face a
beast pirate is like y'all crazy we're
all done for and I love it when hyogoro
responds and so what if we are legendary
stuff indirect contrast to this we see
usop and Hamlet running panicking and
saying I don't want to die then usop's
further scared when he notices the water
hit him then I'm shocked and a bit
annoyed to see that a Tremor made the
sea Stone nail loose and Orochi is able
to use his devil fruit again it's insane
how much Orochi has been through and how
he's still not dead I was really hoping
last time would be it but now he's up
and about he is on fire so it doesn't
look good for him but he is using his
fruit Powers he decides to at least take
kyori with him and he hopes Odin is
watching as he takes the life of his
dear daughter at the very least it seems
like he's convinced he's not gonna make
it for much longer so that's comforting
I look forward to seeing who is the one
who saves hiri leave your predictions in
the comments and at this point though
like I can't assume oroch is gonna die
100 because this dude just freaking
keeps going the power of mythical zones
it's crazy then Luffy mid-fight with
kaido says Hey Momo and then both Yamato
and Momo are shocked to see Luffy's
giant fist come out of the heavens it
really is depicted like the hand of God
or something like that no doubt that
this is a Godly devil fruit the fist is
way bigger than even the giant form we
saw before it's coded in hockey
including conquerors hockey and it's
dwarfing kaido in size making it look
like he could squish kaido as if he were
a bug Luffy says he's finishing kaido
for good and that onigashima is in the
way and Momo has to move it ASAP we see
a different perspective and Luffy's fist
is practically the size of the floating
island absolutely insane in my all 11
mythical zones Link in the description I
pointed out that kaido used to be the
big mythical Zone transformation but now
Luffy has proven in the last few
chapters that he can become even bigger
ridiculously big with a hand like this
he could grab kaido and squish him in
his fist size wise at least Momo is
freaking out and Luffy just says I know
you've got this and he's smiling as if
he's just going to do it with complete
faith and Momo it's hilarious I love it
and Momo is horrified since he seems to
have like a few seconds to figure all
this out even kaido looks moved by the
sheer size and Threat Level of Luffy's
attack narrator says the Fallout from
this Mighty blow dot dot dot which is
exciting to think about kaido likes
dodging but this won't be so easy to
dodge because not only is the size
almost undodgeable but Luffy is even
holding kaido with his other hand so I
have no doubt that this attack will land
and that does make me feel a bit better
about the lightning one missing but wow
ridiculous and epic stuff I love this
chapter I gotta say let me know your
thoughts will this fight wrap up with
Luffy's giant fist or will kaido turn
the tables once more during the course
of this fight MVP must go to Luffy great
stuff but props to Momo for his
development throughout the story I just
love seeing how much trust Luffy has in
his crew and allies it's amazing how he
can just fight and not worry about
anything because he knows his crew and
allies have got this and the key here is
that this is a hockey infused fist so
it's almost like Luffy letting kaido
know I'm not just a strong devil fruit
user I got the hockey Mastery to back it
up as well so this attack should check
all the boxes for delivering a
satisfying Victory against kylo anyways
if you did enjoy this review and want to
keep them coming you know what to do
Channel parking with it and smash that
like button with no mercy remember
smashing his pirate king energy and
passing his Scarlet Orochi energy so
Choose Wisely if you ever make this the
video subscribe and hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and updates while you
wait for the next chapter to drop feel
free to check out my growing one piece
playlist that includes videos on all the
yonko Warlords mythical zones and much
more link that is in the description and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys